The Joe Rogan Experience where's the
Barbie movie
no I have not no sir
a lot of people are upset about the
Barbie movie and I left perplexed
did you see it yeah it was a fun movie
was it good fun silly movie about dolls
who come to life but it's you know a lot
of it is about the patriarchy sure and
you know it's a comedy it's a comedy
about dolls people who are like you know
people are upset that it's this
you know like Progressive metaphor for
life that it's you know that they're
pushing Progressive politics in this I'm
like it's a [__] doll movie yeah it's
a doll movie yeah it's a fun movie about
dolls who come to life and try to
interact with the real world and there's
this lady in it who's this mom who I'm
spoiler alert who makes Barbie feel sad
because she's playing with Barbie and
she has sad feelings it's it's a [__]
interesting movie It's like because I
was like wow this is a original movie
like no one's ever done a movie like
this before it's not like anything else
you could say it was it was bizarre
movie but it was a fun silly movie I
laughed but at the end of it I was like
how did people get outraged at that like
it make they were saying it's I know
some people personally who said it's
anti-men I'm like no it's it's making
fun of dorks it's it's making fun it's
fun it's you didn't think it was fun
like if that was a real person that
happening to them isn't that fun well
Mario and Ryan are just like
amazing amazing together in that movie
too I have to say it I I want to see it
I enjoyed it I just didn't understand
why people were getting so upset like do
you think that's you are they making fun
are they are you are all men in this one
are we gonna do this thing where we put
all men as men it's one category that
we're not going to judge people as
individuals right we're going to pretend
that these individual in this milk who
are clearly dorks because they're
designed it's fun that you don't think
like what happens to them and the way it
happens isn't like fun like I don't
understand like why people think that
represents all men it's the dumbest the
dumbest sort of how does it like how
what it what is it what was the so the
you said
they think it's a super woke movie and
uh
I just that's the way to make a [__]
movie but it's also a movie about how
Barbies are the the top the dolls that
everyone cares about and Ken is just a
[__] accessory which is real so when
you bring these things into a movie you
make them real life Barbie land right
that's how they have to be because
that's how it is in the real world like
that's the movie right and then the
movie they go to the real world the real
world sucks and it's run by men and so
this is what people are saying makes
this an answer that's a good concept
though it's a [__] fun movie man I
don't get it I just I'm I'm
appalled at how easily outraged so many
people are I could see if you don't like
it I could see if you it wasn't your
kind of movie but that's anything that
someone oh that means well to be honest
to be fair about that like it's also
like
you said it's not your kind of movie
it's also the Barbie movie right you
have to kind of you have to kind of like
you can't go in there walking so
seriously right about it right why would
you go to see AC DC if you [__] hate
AC DC yeah yeah if you if you're like
into classical it's just to make fun of
Brian Johnson be like you're no bond
[__] Scott man you know that that's
I'm scared of that [__] I'm scared that
people buy tickets to come and make fun
of me that's like my biggest fear that's
my biggest fear I haven't seen it yet
and hopefully don't see that but it's
all right because I still sold a ticket
yeah good
and sit in the front with your frown on